die mannheimer hand kartenglück sind
immer wichtig sei es menschen für uns
alle da ich mich mit dem hund und donner
weil ich glaub schon 13 12 36 780 an
ihren haben immer geteilt will ich bin
schuldig beschuldigt da bin ja schon ein
totales gebrochenes kinder mutter im
wald und ich einfach mein sohn ist hus
ich habe nichts gespürt mini toni
seifert funktioniert und so habe ich es
gesehen nach dem tod total abgelöscht
und sie sind ruhig sieben gestorben ist
im gegenteil
total ist dass da endlich die nach iris
khanna hatte einen schweren start ins
leben
ihr vater direktor eines chemiekonzerns
ist brauchte sie jahrelang aufs
schändlichste und als die kleine iris
allen mut zusammen nahm und das
schweigen brach erschoss er sich
gleichen 80 lebensjahre um diese wunden
zu heilen und kann das leben nach so
viel unglück doch noch eine glückliche
wendung nehmen davon handelt diese
fehlen
[Musik]
was hält er fort mit ihnen gemacht
ein objekt ein fachbuch tops mine gab
thomas krücken geht's nicht
er hätte mehr brauchtum ihn oral
befriedigen den ohren und der hoch und m
manuell bis mir abgefallen ist
und schlimm wenn ich den eigentlich
gesehen wenn man dennoch eher das q
siegel müssen im buch als er habe sich
seitdem immer zum distanz geht aber ich
habe das gesehen und rache und dass ich
dann alles wurst für den handel - im
badezimmer version haben ihn und er hat
mir den namen atome in der sonne
rollstuhl sitzen
von jannik sasse zu metallurge ich werde
immer gefroren ich bin immer mit wolken
am himmel oder pflegen auf und denke mir
jetzt eigentlich gar nicht gar und ton
an ich wollte immer so lang als stripper
zum see
ich bin doch gar nicht 1986 erschienen
neuseeland ihres goalies bestseller
ich weinte nicht als vater staat das
buch braucht die tabuisierung des vater
tochter inzests monate lang führt der
ihres goalies lebensgeschichte die
bestseller listen auf der ganzen welt an
schreiben als therapie nach dem
missbrauch der 100 musiker verlassen
empfinde meine persische hilfe besonders
lied war in ihrem selbst gestört wurde
sein auto durch messbuch in der
opferrolle bleibe sind und ich sage
wichtigste ich probiere aus der
opferrolle co aber
wir empfehlen mehr als schweizer und
internationale bestseller autorin und
nicht als selbst therapieren dich hier
ist ali lebt in einer bescheidenen
wohnung in peace werden
sie sagt sie könnte heute
multi-millionärin sein hätte er erster
verleger sie nicht um die tantiemen ihre
bücher gefehlt ihre botschaft verbreitet
sie weiter in romanen und einem
theaterstück über psychisch kranke
eltern und ihren kindern wenn kinder
ständig übernommen den sie sich den
später nazistisch entwickelt das heißt
sie dir zu den hierzulande quasi nicht
überhand selber wählen und werteten
egoistisch und wenn man sich gestört
dass bienen aus ob sie ja furchtbar also
780 gestört alles wie gehabt
richtig stört dass man durch da galt es
dann wenn man es immer für zelle für
zelle für zelle wo was ein passiert ist
dass wir verstanden wird will man weiß
man ist und solange natürlich immer
wieder aufmerksamkeit heißt doch dazu
waren und minderwertigkeitskomplex
solange stoß mit den telefonen
er ist alles unglück war mit dem tod des
vaters nicht zu ende
mit 20 heiratete sie einen älteren mann
der sie schlug die ehe zerbrach das
sorgerecht für die gemeinsame tochter
oder dem vater übertragen
auch die ehe mit ihrem zweiten mann ging
in die brüche
die tochter aus dieser beziehung lebt
heute in australien heute mit 80 ist
iris kalle glücklich vor zehn jahren hat
sie im pensionierten lokomotivführer
peter gruber die linke ihres lebens
gefunden und seiner seite tauchten
bisher unbekannte gefühl werden ein
[Musik]
absolut die geborgenheit zum ersten mal
und du mich liebst und ich erklärt
mithilfe damit wir mit dem als lieber
wählen
nominiert sind aber im moment irrsinnig
so absolute gehorsam leisten erwartet
den späteren frau kontrollieren und
dominant und mit mir merken dass mit den
anderen als dominant wird und können
überall ist auf geräte und darüber
unsere beziehen und er sich sicher 8 und
toth sie geboren und ich raus geglaubt
wurde ist der schmuck sehr und ich denke
das wäre jetzt wie die frau und das ist
fatal york und sich dort wurde
[Musik]
und ja die glücklichste frau ist schön
aber die frauen keine einfache
geschichte ist es schwer aus hemer ihrer
dank hoffentlich deutlich dass nicht
stark aber sie hat das total super
und dank dem man sie mit ihrer eigenen
therapie hat sie das super geschafft und
spürt jetzt erst dämmert es brauchte
allerdings jahrzehnte harte arbeit und
therapie bis calais sich anderen
gegenüber normal verhalten konnte um
sich und ihre wirkung auf ihre
mitmenschen noch besser zu verstehen
machte sie sogar eine ausbildung zur
traumatherapeutin und hilft nun anderen
missbrauchsopfern nur ein kurzes intro
grenze überschritten von mir und
insofern hätte mir wie erinnere
glaubwürdigkeit zu mir selber gar will
ich bei andere stürme dazu ich bin
verschoben sagt so empfunden und das
nimmt dem stück oder endlose einsamkeit
und sich darin bewegt will man fühlt
sich fremd man fühlt sich anders wird
oftmals anders taxiert weil man
verhaltensweisen zeigt wo auf mal extrem
sind und das sind so momente wo mir
stütze boten
auch die beziehung zu peter gruber war
am anfang schwierig denn als disc alle
klar wurde dass aus ihrer verliebtheit
etwas ernstes entstehen könnte wurde sie
von ihren auf bekannten gefühlen
übermannt
sie suchte er vertraute kunsttherapeutin
auf in der hoffnung dass diese zwischen
peter und ihr vermitteln könnte aber
noch viel schöner ist all das könnte die
für die erinnerung rufen wenn sie wieder
torschütze diese dankbarkeit dass ihr
hierzu sonst reden wenn ich will schwarz
sie hat zum ersten mal im jahre wirklich
alles riskiert zum das sage was ich
hatte mein vater dörfer ohne angestimmt
mir sterben dafür dass sie die mpu zu
sagen ja verstört reagiert genau das
stand in aussicht dass sie beide
sozusagen zusammen wohnen wollten und
dann entstand die panik und sehe ich
mich dann an christa kannst du mir
helfen jetzt rede ich völlig durch ich
mache alles kaputt als fazit sieht neben
vater messbuch auf die rübe zügig kann
ich mal sterbe
wenn ich nicht mit einem arschloch wenn
er das will und hat somit mehr golas
kind und in der ehe bin ich dem
entleeren von bruce und angstattacken
der klage und hat das mittelmeer golo
und heimat denkt ja dass ich sie dreht
bietet für absoluten erhielt er sich
nicht total für freie und das
musikmachen sind wirklich liebt und es
war dann ganz wichtig dass ich einmal
für die iris ihren partner erkläre
offenbar wie das für sie
ist weil mit der sexualität für sich nur
freude sondern ganz fürchterliche
assoziationen verknüpft sind laut
grenzüberschreitung und so weiter hier
sehen wir den anfang
der mond ist ein kreuz die augen nicht
sehen nicht sprechen und dann sehen wir
hier wie die er ist das malt und das
schwarz sind nicht haare wie sie sagt
sondern das ist der nebel die
vernebelung und das ist die verwirrung
das ist ein typisches kennzeichen bei
missbrauchs kindern weil sie das
geschehene nicht einordnen können es ist
ihnen nicht möglich vor allem wenn
geschieden wird und wenn wir mal die
länge des penis anschauen und stellen
uns vor der würde da reingehen dann
reicht der bisher und das ist bedeutungs
perspektive wie sie das erlebt hat und
dann kann ich doch eine plötzlich
einfach nur sich denn die skis schwanz
von acht bis 80 immer im labor peter
hamm ideen ihrer erfahrung und ein stück
weit mittragen wird
und das ist wohl das machtwort teppich
alles hätte ich alle die wollen immer
das wohl nix hat mir einfach die post
will das sächsische diermann regen
wunder und liebe und den worten der
vorführsaal mit genannt musa wir wollen
dass sie und das sex und das ist
unglaublich befreiend sehe alles und ich
bitte auf und zieht den helm ohne
probleme und petrik lieberman
und wenn ich keine lust habe keine
gemähte durch bemüht oder magnetisch und
ertrank und ich immer schön war muss das
glück hat iris kalle gefunden
erst im alter zwar dafür umso
überwältigender aus seinem vermögen der
investmentbanker der anonym bleiben will
das frisch verliebte paar an einem bau
tanzen sagt schenkt er den beiden dieses
häuschen in sachsen anhalt sieht sich zu
mir stand und mich getraut sagte das
möchte das möchte ich nicht sie dem tier
nicht ganz andere mussten nehmen die
halte und sie das glück hier war
wunderbar also tätig erklärt und die
hochzeit und jetzt dass ich mein wahres
hilfe und drei minuten das beste
investment
so verbringt das paar das sommerhalbjahr
dass in deutschen ohren c
iris kolles lebensgeschichte scheint mit
einem happy end zu schließen
jenen missbrauchsopfern in denen die es
nicht vergönnt ist wird mit sie buch um
buch und ich habe meine inzest kongress
kleb- und gehört habe viel säugling und
zwei und dreijährige hände und durch
penetration von ihrem vater oder da und
ich mir geschworen ich wäre jetzt
einfach sprache durch schriebe durch
alles was ich mache
zu dem thema zum kampf gegen sexuellen
missbrauch verhindern dass sich so eine
große ungerechtigkeit was mit literatur
die einige ältere und was das mit der
liebe macht und denn was man weitermacht
mit denen sind wir keine bindung kräftig
vor einem selber unter seinem körper
wirklich zeigt was mir neu
ja genau
erst vor anderthalb jahren haben ihre
skalen und ihre tochter antwortet sich
nach langen jahren des schweigens
versöhnt und damit toni genannt wurde
nach der scheidung ihrem vater
zugesprochen und wuchs in einer
pflegefamilie auf mutter und tochter
dürften sich besonders ins
teenager-alter kam nur jedes dritte
wochenende sehen
das ist ein business für sie beide dass
sie so vertraut und leuten oder und doch
ist das wirklich toll zwei gott du
irgendwann bist und verhinderte so viele
flüsse dort doch ihr traum aber immer
mit im spiel immer wieder der vorwurf
gemacht
doch wenn du das gemacht und weiß doch
dass es so gemacht wie schön dass du das
gesehen
doch als kind war es für uns nicht
schwierig zu verstehen warum die mutter
immer wieder und viel zu früh von
verbrechen erzählte dass an ihr begangen
worden war
einiges ist und wie schwierig sie und
kommen als sie hört minute an verbissen
wie eine dicke schicht und ich wenn du
herum oder nicht verletzt
vielleicht so hoch wie schon wieder
verletzt ist dass da so eine dicke wolke
wieder ist dazwischen oder was sie -
nicht ein ziemlich schlechtes gewissen
der ton gegenüber was sie aussieht
wissen quasi tote also niederschlags
krise sondern die figur aber die figur
darüber war so eine gestörte menschen
gestört
über generationen mit ihm dran war
verantwortungslos einfach aus wie sie
der kinder und der märkte kinder und und
zur liter das macht ohne und victor ich
die beziehung zu ihrer jüngeren tochter
easy ist gänzlich zerstört diese lebt
mit ihrem mann in australien
sie hat jeglichen kontakt mit ihrer
mutter abgebrochen und gibt mir ein
interview bei sky ich habe mit meiner
mutter gebrochen weil unsere beziehung
sehr schwierig ist wenn sie da ist habe
ich das gefühl dass ich nicht existiere
ich fühle mich nicht gesehen und nicht
gehört
alles dreht sich um sie
das ist keine beziehung es gibt einen
schweizer kinderspiel
ich weiß nie wann die böse böse katze
kommt ich fühle mich bei ihr nicht
sicher ich verstehe was trauma bedeutet
ich habe mitgefühl mit ihr ich liebe sie
sehr aber es tut einfach zu wie sie
erwartet wahrscheinlich dass ich
irgendetwas tun könnte
aber das kann ich nicht und es ist auch
nicht meine aufgabe
die aktuellste vettel ja schön dass sie
sich ein paar schon lange möglich
22 wenn sie keine so soll diese grenze
traurig und langes interview gemacht mit
der easy und sich seit sie wird
möglichkeit kontakt mit denen mehr und
die dafür war ja wenn sich im moment
also und ich habe mich mama weisen
abschließen
es kommt leben wir
[Musik]
iris kalle konnte nicht weinen aus ihr
vater sich aus dem leben gestohlen hat
die tränen fließen jahrzehnte später in
der schatten des missbrauchs sich über
ihre nachkommen liegt
[Musik]